oh hello my Tiger Queen hello my Tiger
king
welcome everybody to easy live at home
I'm Lauren Zima I'm Danny direct over
here to give you your pop culture fix in
the South 14 times and what perfect
timing because there is one thing that
hit Netflix that everybody is talking
about right now hence our leopard print
and that's the tiger King take a look
it's not every day that a zookeeper with
the prison for murder for hire there are
more captive Tigers in the u.s. then
there are in the wild throughout the
world they don't people are nuts man
they're all crazy
okay now first of all I love that we
both had an animal print option we have
access to our entire wardrobe I could
change every hour okay here's my thought
and I'm only two episodes into tiger
King it's so well made I'm so hooked and
it is exactly what we needed right now
because it's the first time my mind has
been taken completely off of the corona
virus pandemic and all it took was let
me see if I get this right a a nearly
paralyzed sensational gay roadside
exotic animal owner of over a hundred
big cats in a polygamous relationship
and his rival include an alleged husband
killer and a possible cult leader like
what is happening and that thing that
hooks you because I'm only one episode
in but I was talking about how you know
using these two crime docu-series you
can't there's a lot of setup to get to
the good stuff but the setup here you're
introduced to these cast of characters
that that's that's the one reason the
first reason I should say to watch it is
because they're still out there you have
Joe exotic this gay polygamous big cat
owner and then his rival Carol basket
and she's over here with her flower
pound at cat Coachella like I was like
who are these people and I as we learn
like they are rivals legally and it just
takes like a darker and darker turn the
more candy you have so I mean I'm only
on episode 2 and already so much has
changed this series delivers on the
promise of it you don't know what's
happening next you don't know who to
root for here which is weird because in
the first episode it's revealed that Joe
exotic is in jail so I know blows your
mind out even in episode 2 um like wait
who's the real villain what is right and
long story short this insanity is the
level that we needed to distract us from
the real world
it's so truth making us feel better
about our own lives in a lot of ways you
know they're not and it's no surprise
that people like Kim Kardashian Zach
Braff
I think it's a janae I go everyone's
tweeting about it I want some cooped up
at home like this is the kind of
entertainment that we needed and I will
say we also spoke to the director and he
told us if people think this is scripted
like I think again
guess again because sometimes we truth
is stranger than fiction and that's the
case here I mean even the backstory
about this has started as like a it was
a New York magazine investigative
feature turned into a podcast and these
people just followed these
documentarians followed these big cat
breeders for like six years and
everything kind of hold it in real time
in front of all the timing i had tweeted
and i know i think this was already set
to come out but I tweeted it Netflix yo
if you got anything in the can wrap it
now like he doesn't have to be back
great our standards are pretty low I
wish actually that love is blind has
started a little bit later so that we
just called could have experienced it
together but thankfully we have tiger
king and Danny I mean you think that you
have a hand on you think okay
allegations of murder people who are
into big cats I'm gonna look and then
you're like oh I'm so sorry did you say
he was in a polygamous marriage right
did you say he was an alleged cult
leader like yes gets Wilder so it gets
as wild as the cats but it's about we
love it we can stand for it and I'm here
for it I'm definitely gonna keep
watching I'm surprised I didn't finish
it in one night well I love that it's
giving us all something to watch
together because everything that we're
experiencing right now is a separation
that's making us want together ness and
you know people helping people even in
the corona times Chrissy Teigen is of
course doing her usual amount of cooking
and baking but things are sparse at the
grocery stores and she just needs some
romaine lettuce right things are flying
off the shop and she's so desperate for
this romaine lettuce who knows if she
making a Caesar salad I don't know but
he's willing to literally exchange
banana bread in exchange for this
lettuce that she so desperately needs
and it's so funny to me because I'm know
Chrissy Teigen but I'll tell you what
this quarantine has made me realize that
like I can [ __ ] I've been cooking a lot
but supplies are scarce what have you
been running out of I don't know if
you're cooking are you cooking Oh
what I'm not a salad duty every night
cuz it's like actually not cooking it's
just sort of putting things together I
can make a great shark ooh yeah I make a
salad so again just sort of about
putting these together in a bowler on a
plate but no like he involved I can't do
that okay so then you understand
Chrissy's pain like you also are in need
of romaine lettuce
I was so but I greens have been flying
off the shelves and what's hard about
that is we all need to keep our immune
systems up and keep our nutrients solid
right now so again I would ask everybody
buy what you need the grocery store
enemies as much as they can but yeah
I've been making a Caesar - little wedge
salad what is funny to me about this too
is remember this was a while ago but
member when Chrissy Teigen needed
bananas for banana bread she was driving
around La was a really ripe bananas and
now it's full circle now she's gonna
make someone banana bread for romaine
lettuce and the chain will continue what
I love is that she was setting the
example of you know still social
distancing as LA is in shelter-in-place
and she said who has romaine lettuce
I'll trade you for the banana bread but
no funny stuff we will keep our distance
when we train well listen while Chrissy
is running low on lettuce we have plenty
of beef today okay let's talk about it
what year is it Lauren because Kim
Kardashian reignited her beef with
Taylor Swift you and I were saying I
mean the question during all of this has
been what day is it like it's try to
keep track and then you said now that
this cam Kanye video recording feud has
been reignited it's like what year is it
this started in 2016
you thought it already felt like Ron
Groundhog's Day because of this
quarantine I mean now the news cycle is
starting to repeat and I think again
four years ago was when Kim first
released those snapchat videos alleging
that Taylor fully knew that she was
gonna be in Kanye's song famous and of
course that ignited four years of fan
feuds and their whole drama
we got the reputation era from Taylor
what's back again and my question for
you Lauren is is now a good time for
them to be going at it again on social
media well it's hard right because what
happened is now this
full video has been somehow leaked
nobody knows how it came to light again
but it's the full video and so Taylor
did comment on it and said you know but
there are more important things
happening in the world right now so
let's focus on that Kim then starts
tweeting about it a lot of tweets and
she's also saying look this almost seems
silly if she goes in - she goes in - I
know and that's I can't imagine what
it's like to have this type of feud to
feel that you've experienced a level of
injustice for four years I mean this
feud has been on a presidential campaign
a presidential term I mean for us this
feud has been presiding over us and I
didn't need it to be reignited again I
wish there was a way to completely avoid
it but on the other hand for both Kim
and Taylor I don't know how when you've
probably got millions of tweets coming
at you I don't know how you say nothing
you really have to go high-rise but I
would say I didn't need this right now I
will say the other part of me the sick
twisted part you know where I'm here and
I am in desperate need of some
entertainment and so I'd be lying if I
didn't say I put pause on the Netflix
and started reading all the tweets cuz I
was like okay she I mean she really was
going off and then you throw in todrick
Hall who did Taylor on Instagram stories
I mean what todrick was saying could you
decipher it was if there's such text on
the screen on my phone screen I
pinch-to-zoom I was like we gotta say I
mean he really was just kind of calling
out Kim for being a hypocrite and also
explain I think the the biggest gripe
that he has and a lot of fans have is
Kim on one of our tweets claims she's
like I didn't edit the footage I only
posted some of them on snapchat arguably
can that's editing the original footage
right because you're only showing some
of it I mean this feud is subjective for
sure and that's what I think has helped
to go on for so long and what was hidden
and what hasn't been hidden and who's
said what and who's kept quiet I just
will say at the end of the day I I crave
togetherness right now not good
you know and so I hope we can I don't
know maybe does there's a little part of
me that wants it to be like a Taylor and
Katy moment like Annie extend an olive
branch can they expect that's I'm gonna
predict that's never gonna happen I'm
gonna happen here I really don't
Taylor's like a squash one beat this one
is just gonna be seared forever until
it's well done and it's getting there
it's medium-well right now the last
thing I will say is like I don't feel
like Kim needed to go off like that on
Twitter last night but I will thank
Kanye B because because I love this
drama we got reputation which i think is
one of his best albums and I tor was so
late so yeah well and it's Kim is
defending you know her man that's like I
think that's a thing to about dispute is
it's so personal it's so intense like
for Kim that's the father of her
children and yeah I mean long story
short not what I expected to see in
terms of Twitter t right now I thought
it was mostly you know gonna be I don't
know Tiger King fodder and people coming
after our politicians or Lady Gaga
postponing achromatic oh she postpones
her album release and she released this
statement to fans and at first I was
kind of like what why because this is a
time when we're all craving content I
know some artists have even seemingly
pushed up releases what they have but
once I read through Gaga statement I did
see that what she was basically saying
is like it doesn't feel right it doesn't
feel right to her she doesn't feel as
though her and her fans could enjoy it
in the way that she wants to you know
with the dance parties and then the
performances and and the feel of it also
I understand that like as an artist
that's your personal work and if you
don't feel good about it then don't do
it it's also her personal convictions
and she's Gaga said in that statement to
her fans that she also wanted to shift
the focus to just like rebuilding
communities who've been affected by
coronavirus and making sure that like
everyone's get the help that they need
so mother knows best
okay mother Monster has spoken we will
follow her leave her let's not bury the
lead from that statement apparently she
had a secret Coachella set
the bad news keeps piling up for it you
mean I missed it I'm not gonna see so
everybody knows Danny hath not missed a
Coachella for many a year who would have
been right there front and center I know
you would have with bells and whistles
and love that she said I promise you
that when we can go out again I'm gonna
make it so much fun and I believer so
it'll be worth it we're gonna sweat
together when we auction exactly but
quickly obviously for a lot of people
including both of us actually
we're self quarantine with our bays and
we have been seeing a lot of
relationships being affected by the
quarantine including Oprah oh oh Oprah I
mean she has been with Stedman for
decades and they're not she talks about
Stedman but you know they're not a super
public couple never have been like sonic
they do interviews together and all that
but did she really say she is banished
to the guest house I mean one house of
many rooms I'm assuming so I should be
okay but here's what she did have to say
about how the accordion has affected how
her relationship with Stedman on
Saturday you've been on planes you've
been an honest and I was like so Sam is
like what's the procedure for coming
home you go in the house I mean the
procedure is you're going to the guest
house come and sleeping in my bed she
says you know what she's the pain
whatever she wants Chris Harrison and I
have been playing what I call Downton
Abbey
upstairs Downstairs like I'm be upstairs
for a minute you be downstairs for a
minute and let's just you know take our
time because I think what is a little
strange
for a lot of people probably in
Hollywood too is that you're used to
being off filming on a movie set filming
a TV show here like Chris would have
been gone for a couple of weeks if not
longer for Bachelorette production and
Bachelorette is on haul unmould so we're
used to being really apart and then
really together and even when we're
together were I still had you know
worked the office to go into everyday
now letting Ella I mean would you mind
me asking remind me how long have you
guys been together we've been together
four and July would be end of July
August would be two years we'll be
teachers see you're going for two years
I'm only eight months into my
relationship and we are living together
for the first time he has his own place
but he's here
in fact he's right next to me so I love
it it's going so well I just you know
I'm so grateful no truly I do feel like
it's brought us closer together and
we're having fun so far so good I
unfortunately don't have a second story
so it's just this story so we did
actually have to have the talk of like
okay if one of us needs mean time to say
so and the other person won't get
offended so thankfully we haven't had to
do that yeah I love that you guys had
that conversation about look if one of
us has to go have some me time let's
just say that let's not be offended
because this isn't even just you moved
in together it's you moved in together
and you can't leave the house so yeah
yeah you can't go grab a drink with your
friends you can't go to a yoga class so
it's a huge jump even if it had been a
normal time in our world and it's not I
think it's all about communication and
we're probably all learning to
communicate better than we ever have and
you got to give yourselves a little
extra grace like that's what Chris and I
have been saying is we just both want to
be a little extra patient with each
other know that even underneath our
tough exterior we're all feeling the
tension of what's going on so you got a
you know very literally love the ones
you're with it's so true and all that no
you know we actually spoke with love is
blind fan-favorites Lauren and Cameron
and they're used to being quarantined
right separately and together and here's
what they told us about their tips to
survive in the quarantine when you're in
a relationship you know the thing about
being together all the time is I feel
like everybody needs a break so I feel
like it's okay to communicate with your
partner like hey I'm gonna take this X
amount of time you just have some me
time go into a different room close the
door or like I gave myself like a little
mini spa night last night I went the
bathroom closed the door gave myself a
facial
okay I'm gave me my space it was great
because even though it's like we're
stuck together I feel like that means
I'm an individual time is still super
important it's good oh you go ahead I
was gonna say Mike you just said Lauren
says you know cam knows when to give her
her space and I think that's really key
too it's like obviously you guys are a
unit and you're doing so many things
together that that like alone time is
kind of important if it's important to
you it's something that you need and
it's important for the other partner to
kind of recognize that well and I think
we're also gonna have some like not
giving space moments I'm gonna get a lot
of corn babies there's gonna be a baby
boom I'm calling it right now Jackson
Britney talked to us about this
Vanderpump rules let's play that clip in
nine months a bunch of babies will be
born for your samples like I'm worried
anything right now have a handle I just
feel like we're gonna be okay
everybody's gonna get through this
together hopefully we can contain
everything quickly if people stay home
and wash their hands yeah watch the hand
and we'll be just fine baby-making time
to make me you know you don't even have
to make time the time has been given to
you now make a baby
now's the time to practice - all right I
love it you know Melissa we I've got a
note of love and and positivity I like
please right exactly
um and for those of you who you know are
actually alone during the corn time now
is a good time to let some love is a
thing - okay and I'm not just saying
that someone who's in a relationship
like now's the time to do that thing
you've always wanted to do learn that
new language do a new hobby do not want
you guys to feel alone because I know
that even if you're quarantine with
somebody like this is a strange mental
and emotional time so that's why et live
is coming to you at home every day with
Danny and I we want to make sure that
you're part of our conversations and we
appreciate you all so much thanks
everybody for staying home and stay safe
we'll see you guys tomorrow
ie
[Music]